vous savez nous notre dossier là on a
connu on a commencé avec le gouvernement
péké ça peut soit le gouvernement
libéral pilote gouvernement kakis
fait pas trop d'illusions ces deux
hommes sont membres d'une coalition
citoyenne formée en 2013 pour faire
cesser une coupe de bois dans l'une des
plus vieilles forêts laurentiennes celle
du Mont kek up qui se trouve à la limite
nord-est de la région on arrive avec un
dossier étoffé on a la population de
notre côté je pense qu'on a des bonnes
chances d'obtenir notre moratoire la
coalition obtient gain de cause devant
les tribunaux en 2014 la coupe de bois
n'aura pas lieu depuis le groupe réclame
du gouvernement la protection permanente
du cakecup de sa biodiversité et des
très vieux arbres souvent bicentenaires
qui recouvre 60% du massif c'est ce que
tous les scientifiques disent pour
lutter contre la crise climatique les
fondements il faut protéger 30% de notre
territoire à l'horizon 2030 pour
protéger des territoires qui sont déjà
riches en biodiversité j'en étais en
étant que comme été oublié dans le temps
il faut rappeler que le Québec est
encore bien à de ça de son objectif de
protection entre autres dans la région
des Laurentides pourtant à Québec la
demande la coalition est au point mort
certains clous vous enfoncez une pub
maintenant quoi 10 ans
on frappe un mur toujours on voit une
banque comme une montagne ordinaire
comme tous les autres montagnes qui a
tous les autres forêts c'est là le
problème les membres de la coalition
estiment que le key Cup est un bijou de
diversité biologique le projet englobe
40 km² de forêt public une zone qu'il
faut protéger distille parce qu'elle a
fait l'objet de nombreuses coupes dans
le passé et qu'elle est aujourd'hui
encerclée de terre privée on a besoin de
vieilles forêt les vieilles forêts
abritent peut-être en 20 40% de plus
d'espèces donc et puis quand on sait que
peut-être 50% des espèces qui sont
encore méconnues ou moins connus dans le
monde le de précautions s'applique
depuis 10 ans la coalition a pourtant
pris des bouchées doubles des études sur
la faune la flore et l'impact économique
de la montagne une évaluation de son
potentiel récré au touristique et des
fonds de 250 000 dollars consacrés à la
recherche sur le terrain il y a beaucoup
de gens qui appuient la coalition il y a
des professionnels qui a pu la coalition
il y a des chercheurs qui occupent
intellectuellement le sommet du mont
kykup actuellement donc ça ça envoie un
message que c'est plus nécessairement le
chantier de coupe qui est un problème
mais l'idée de couper le bois ou de
gérer nos forêts telles qu'on le fait
aujourd'hui le groupe a également obtenu
le soutien d'une douzaine de mères de la
région nous à Sainte-Agathe on y croit
énormément l'environnement et protégeant
un air comme le mont Kalk up c'est
primordial pour l'environnement les en
protéger c'est quelque chose on dirait
que personne n'est habitué de travailler
puis c'est compliqué avec tout le monde
puis on se fait entendre mais ce que ça
se rend jusqu'à la bonne personne je
passe à temps la cool si on confirme à
Québec elle apporte est encore fermée
pendant toutes ces années là vous êtes
assis à plusieurs reprises avec le
gouvernement
en fin de compte qui qui décide pour les
copariser son mandats ils nous disent le
gouvernement c'est de d'envoyer faire
des coupes quand le ministère de
ressources naturelles est passé et
donner les droits de coupe et en fait le
martelage lui il est là pour faire
bûcher fait qu'on rencontre le bûcher
la question qui se pose maintenant et la
suivante dit la coalition si après 10
ans d'efforts ils sont encore incapables
d'obtenir la protection d'appel 40 km de
forêt dans une région qui en a
grandement besoin qui d'autre au Québec
y parviendra nous c'est un lag
intergénérationnel qu'on va faire avec
ça cette nature là les anciens n'ont
profité est encore intacte on en profite
aujourd'hui on aimerait ça que nos
descendants en profitent également
le projet doit protéger du Mont kyke
représente un 40e de la superficie du
parc du Mont-Tremblant ici normand
Grondin Radio-Canada Sainte-Lucie dès
Laurentides
[Musique]